[Musique]
au milieu de la nuit oui
1h du matin enfin le train s'arrête
brusquement très vite les portières
s'ouvrent puisque ce sont des wagons à
bestiaux des gens pyjama rayés qui se
précipite qui nous font sortir très vite
les aboiements de chien
Lina vous invite à découvrir le podcast
original Simone Veil seul l'espoir
apaise la douleur
réalisé à partir d'un témoignage
exceptionnel restez inédit jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
le tatouage le tatouage ça ne fait pas
mal ma femme on se dit si on est tatoué
c'est que on est plus considéré comme
des numéros mais surtout c'est que on
n'est pas destiné à sortir d'ici
[Musique]
rendez-vous le mercredi 19 octobre pour
découvrir ce podcast événement sur
l'ensemble des plateformes d'écoute